out of the 50 plus movies you've
directed and produced which was the
hardest to find financing for well I
would definitely have to say the first
one she's gonna have it which costs
$175,000 because that was my debut film
as far as a feature film as feature
films go and people think that I did
that film right at the film school there
was a four year period between me
finishing in weiu and she's gonna have
it coming out so it was not like that
and then another one would be a Malcolm
X boom ran out of money in the hand
there go get some money - does it ever
get easier what's easy
what's easy I mean it was easy you know
I wouldn't be I wouldn't have launched a
Kickstarter campaign
it's just weird day five so this is
tough business you know you know that's
and I really Annie can tell you he's one
of my students and every time I'm in
here in LA he helps me but I do not try
to sugarcoat things all to my students
and it'll be a great disservice to them
if I did that so I let them know you
know this this is no guarantee it's
gonna happen for you
you